our universe is full of stars at the end
of their lives some die quietly others
go out in spectacular explosions and
some give birth to black holes if you
have a star a supermassive star that's a
hundred times the mass of the Sun at the
end of its life the core runs out of
fuel there's nothing left to hold it up
and the core collapses down into a black
hole when that happens the enormous
gravity generated at the heart of
supermassive stars runs wild this is the
dying star V Y Canis Majoris it's more
than a billion miles across
like all stars
it's a giant nuclear fusion reactor
pumping energy outward at the same time
the star's extreme gravity crushes
inward for a few million years fusion
and gravity are locked in standoff but
when the star runs out of fuel fusion
stops and the stalemate ends gravity
wins in a millisecond the core shrinks
to a fraction of its original size and a
baby black hole is born immediately it
starts to cannibalize what's left of the
star as matter swirls into the black
hole it gets incredibly hot and there
are magnetic forces and frictional
forces and it's just a witch's brew a
nightmare what's going on right above
the surface of the black hole